for kershaw 22nd start
10-8
looking for a little bit of a bounce
back after his last outing
he has yet to throw more than 75 pitches
in a game since coming off the ils we'll
see what kershaw can do tonight
runner goes throw to second is not in
time but stolen base for wong that's
number of 12 on the season for colt long
just a skinny kid taps one out in front
of the mound kershaw has to fire and he
gets it there in time
terrific play by clayton kershaw
yelich is out
and the brewers come up empty but quick
as a cat he jumps off the mound
and fires a strike to muncie eric lauer
on the hill now for start number 20 ron
yeah he's been terrific i mean his last
14 starts a 6-2 record 178
earned run average he's won three
consecutive decisions and his numbers
against the dodgers off the charts 6-0
189
and a nice pitch and a strikeout for
lauer his first of the game yeah this
has been a pretty hot offense for los
angeles i mean they lead the league and
run scored
they walk a lot they're second in home
runs
bottom of the first trey turner
awaiting the o2 from lauer
swinson hits it a long way down the
right field side
and this ball is gone
a home run trey turner dodger strikes
first it's one nothing
extends his career high at home runs in
a single season to 26.
dodgers have hit 16 home runs in their
last five games
and this one hits
into left and yelich
calls off kane to make the catch for the
final out
no one out here in the second inning
here's lorenzo kane
this one lined in the left that's a base
hit
escobar rounding third he will come home
marias will stop at third and an rbi
double for lorenzo kane and we are tied
1-1
four hits are ready for the brewers
against clayton kershaw who got roughed
up his last timeout
and this one right back and kershaw into
the shift the run is going to score to
give milwaukee a two to one lead as
aureus comes in
good job putting the ball in play the
dodgers were conceding a run to get it
out lorenzo cain gets a lead at third
base dodger infield is in one out
two-two pitch
got up swinging
first strikeout of the game for kershaw
two down and back to the top of the
order
this one hammered in the right of base
hit a clutch hit for wong as he is
rounding first down his way to second
with a two out rbi double and milwaukee
now in front three to one he's just his
fourth start since coming off the il and
he's coming out
clayton kershaw has to leave after
an inning in two thirds
[Applause]
ground ball in the first pitch to seeger
as
really against grounds out and
the second night in a row he gets a one
pitch out that ends in it how about that
for the bazooka
here's the payoff
and a nice curveball in for strike three
i was waiting for chad fairchild to ring
him up kind of a delayed reaction wasn't
it i mean he does give the
verbal strike sign right away
and then kind of just a delay to
make it tough on the broadcaster here's
aj [ __ ] rock and i are
at american family field by the way
here's the ground ball and a nice pick
over there by escobar wow as urease's
throw in the dirt
one down here in the third the one
pulled down the right field line for a
base hit for escobar that's going to get
all the way into the corner and rattle
around
yell at you around third he's headed for
home and he is going to be in there
safely
escobar all the way to second and the
brewers lead it four to one
this one right up the middle base hit
and escobar being waved home
here comes the throw it's gonna be late
and milwaukee adds to its lead it's now
five to one that's grounded out the
third as first time huh here's the 2-2
that strikes out
got him on a cutter it looked like
first pitch right to escobar
and a double play indeed as lauer covers
first base nicely
thanks pal
this one lifted in the right garcia busy
inning can he get there no it's going to
be escobar
really shallow right for the third out
so we are through four
two outs for trey turner
turner homeward in the first one for two
tonight
swings the first pitch and drives it to
left center forward and deep this ball
is gone
it's a grand slam for trade turner
he ties the game
oh how do you like it
brand new ball
[Applause]
on the first pitch with seven home runs
they're gonna end up having a losing
record man no kidding
surprise just a hard one to believe
a little number caught by escobard a
nice quick one two three inning for
gustave here in the six we head to the
seventh still
bouncer toward third glove by turner
flips on to turner
just to the tray
stretch time five five dodgers and
brewers
matt baity's gonna pinch it in the
pitcher's spot
[Music]
dodgers lead it six
and now the base is full of dodgers for
justin turner
goes to the backstop and here comes
murky he'll score the wild pitch and the
dodgers lead it 7-5
and
[Applause]
on his way home
and it's an eight to six game as
vogelback delivers the pinshit rbi
single and kenley trying to finish
things off
popped up this will do it as max maxi
puts it away and the dodgers win their
104th
game of the season
you